>> I think the point is about India being
a superpower.
I think it's [INAUDIBLE] about an objective,
and with what power
actually means.
Let's look at power first.
I think if we were look at either India in
either the dimension of
talent, in the dimension of power, it could
be many things to many
people.
To me, I think fundamentally, we are a very
tolerant country.
So intrinsically, we have the ability to do
what people wanted to do,
so I think tolerance, the underlying essence
of what we do and our
focus has been built around that.
To me I think power stems from how we leverage
our inherent
capabilities to develop what we can actually
deliver as a nation.
So power could mean, you know, how do we utilize
our talent pool in the
country?
How to be energized and leverage the natural
resources that's in the
country to actually be far more productive,
self-sufficient.
And the other dimension is the word super.
I think super is an objective, again, is a
superlative in terms of what
we could do as a nation.
If you were to intrinsically leverage some
of the underlying sense of
what power denotes I think we'd be a far better
nation that what we are
today.
You want to me to go ahead?
To go ahead?
It's my favorite topic or you want?
>> Yeah yeah yeah go on.
>> Go ahead?
Okay.
The aspect of -- the essence of India also
lies with how other
countries and nations actually look at India
from their perspective.
I think what people are been typically have
been doing is an inward,
awkward look in terms of saying, hey, this
is the India is the outside
environment, and it's time for the others
to look at us in terms of
what we are capable of.
So today when we hear of, you know, leveraging
India's capabilities,
it's saying, hey, what do you [INAUDIBLE]
is thinking about India, and
what do some of the other nations are thinking
about India.
I think, it's time for India to say hey, this
is what we stand for and
start leveraging some of those.
To me, let's look at some of the dimensions
of what the basic limits of
natures are.
Let's look at water, [INAUDIBLE] and on to
say that to fight for the
world in the next, say, 15, 20 years it's
going to be on water space.
Let's look at energy.
[INAUDIBLE] what power is all about.
So if when we look at some of these dimensions
I think India has got
extreme capability in terms of what we could
do in this space to be
able to achieve what we would typically call
a superpower.
So I think it's in us.
It's each one of us in terms of our ability
to believe in oneself and
say hey I think we are, you know, a nation
which -- that is very proud
of what we do and what we're capable of doing.
So I think self-belief and believing in all
the objectives that come
our way, leveraging our internal capability
is probably the best way to
look at what we could do as a nation.
Yeah?